قريه هادئه على اطراف مدينه انطاكيا روع
الزلزال سكونها
لم يبقي بيتا فيها دون ان يترك على واجهته
ندبه او يحطمه بشكل كامل
يتفقد صادق وصيره ما بقي من حطام منزلهما
تحت هذا الركام انتشل جثمان طفله لم تكمل
بعد ثلاث سنوات
لم نستيقظ بعد الهزه الاولى وفي الثانيه
ايقظني ابي واخذت ابنتي وبدات اركض علقنا
في السلم وبدا البيت يتداعى فوق رؤوسنا
فسقطنا الى اسفل البناء نجى الجميع
باستثناء ابنتي
فقدت القريه حوالي ثلاثين من ابنائها في
الزلزال الحياه تكاد تتوقف فيها وباتت
تعتمد على المساعدات
اما اهلها فخسر كثير منهم ماشيته وما بقي
منها على قيد الحياه ينتظر الانتشال وفرق
الانقاذ لم تصل بعد
نصب يوسف هذه الخيمه في باحه منزله وفيها
يرعى والده المريض وامه التي اصيبت بكسر
في ذراعها اثناء هروبها من البيت خلال
الهزه الاولى
الى بقيهم الا وصل حفيد لانقاذنا وبعدها
نظرت الى البيت وقد ذهب كل شيء لم يبقى
لنا شيء ضع كل ما نملك بعد اصابته اتصلنا
بالاسعاف انتظرنا وانتظرنا ولم ياتي احد
في ساحه القريه يجتمع شيوخها يقول احدهم
انما حدث شبيه بيوم القيامه خلال سنوات
عمرهم الطويله يقولون انهم لم يروا شيئا
يشبهوا ما راوه يوم الزلزال
وحد زلزال بين سكان المدينه وسكان القريه
في الخسائر الماديه والبشريه وان كان وصول
المساعدات وفرق الانقاذ الى مركز ولايه
هاتاي قد استغرق اياما فان وصولها الى
قراها اكثر تاخرا ويخشى سكان القرى
المتضرره من ان تتاخر كذلك عمليه اعاده
اعمار بيوتهم